[Music]
on today's show we talked to a mother
about generational obesity we also
talked to a husband and father who is
planning for divorce and wants to know
how to take care of his kids we talked
to a woman who's a new nurse and she's
struggling with the trauma she sees stay
tuned
[Music]
what is
up everybody this is john with the dr
john deloney show
so glad you're tuning in
and you are riding with us
figuring out whatever
next thing we're gonna do
next actually
um all right this show comes with a
warning
here's the warning
james kelly benjamin
this comes with a couple of warnings one
this is a uh do as i say not as i do
number two this comes with a this is my
confession warning
number three it comes
with a
complete and total
unpaid shout out
to the toyota prius
that kept me alive so here's what
happened
today i was driving to work
oh man today i was driving to work team
and
i was doing some weem huff breathing
exercises on my phone
and they felt incredible
and if you've ever done weem hof
breathing exercises if you haven't you
should and if you have you know how
incredible it is usually do it in ice or
in cold and i was doing it while i was
driving not great
and
then
you get into somewhat of like a
meditative state and it was awesome and
i was still driving
and then i thought i'm gonna do another
round
and the next thing i know i hit the
concrete median at 85 or 90 miles an
hour in my prius
and the prius is totaled
i'm okay
my body's pretty beat up
and here's the thing i couldn't stop
where i was because i was on a turn
coming off of an interstate on to
another interstate
i don't know you can't triple stable
double stand were they both interstates
i don't know it's coming off a fast road
onto another fast road
to all you urban planner listeners out
there of which by the way we have a
bunch of urban planners who listen to
this show
um
and civil engineers
shout out civil engineers and
i had to just keep driving otherwise i
would have
been the big dead and the prius made it
all the way and even so much so that i
was looking at all the bruises and burns
on my arm from stuff and
it kept going and i thought maybe i just
imagined this it wasn't so bad and then
i pulled into the parking lot here and i
got out and looked at it
it's probably the last time that car is
ever gonna be driven ever ever ever
um
but
unpaid shout out to the toyota prius
gang
you saved this guy's life so way to go
i'm team t i'm team toyota prius
and i'm gonna have to get a new car
anyway so there we go this is the most
john doloni story i've ever heard
wrecked his prius while doing breathing
exercises going 85 miles an hour while
listening to
i was i had a metallica shirt on and
i just turned off motley crew and
thought i don't need this to start my
day i need to
yeah it's a very john dalone show and
then the fact that i kept driving and
then i was made it on time for the first
shoot that we had this morning
but my head feels a little bit wobbly
anyway i'm gonna need both of you which
let's be honest y'all or feel free to do
this anytime but y'all just have to
pitch in with some no you didn't give a
very good answer on that one did you get
a concussion
i i i honestly all of my heart have no
idea it was such a
if you could look at the car it's pretty
rough man it's pretty awesome
but that said
uh
i was gonna sing i will survive but
that's not really a good thing i will
survive i did i did survive and i'm a
here's the behavioral changes i'm gonna
make number one i'm gonna start driving
slower i'm gonna drive the speed limit
that's from this point forward that
means i'm gonna have to leave earlier
that's a whole other thing
and two i'm not gonna meditate or do
breathing exercises in a moving vehicle
ever again effective immediately number
three i'm gonna continue to shout out
the prius even though now all i have
left is my big
truck that's trying to prove something i
don't even know what we're doing with
that but let's just go to kate in denver
and get this show going america i'm
alive let's go to kate what's up kate
hi hi how are you
i'm good how are you it's been it's been
a morning it's been a morning
sounds like it but it's
uh i can hear the sympathy in your voice
thank you for for loving me so much kate
so what's up i'm glad you're okay thank
you what's up
so my husband and i we have two boys
they're nine and seven um
my husband's side of the family is very
my husband and the side of his family
are very they're very obese
my side of the family and myself are not
i'm very active
um how
how do i safely and carefully teach the
boys about weight and
healthy habits
oh that's such a great question
um a couple let me ask you a couple
questions how long have i been married
i'm going on 12 years 12 years all right
is your husband obese
yes tell me about that
and the whole family is they've all
struggled
with weight um
a couple of his siblings have managed to
lose weight but i you know i don't
i don't know what it's like um
fortunately i guess um
they will lose the weight
um but then this kind of just comes back
you know it's hard
hard to keep off i'm sure when it's a
family thing
um
yes and and no um
so
there's gonna be some genetic
predisposition there there's no question
about that and there's also going to be
some
tendencies some just natural
inclinations
but there's gonna be a big chunk of this
is gonna be model behavior this is how
we live this is how we eat this is who
we are this is what we do for fun this
is what we do for stress this is what we
do for hurt or pain etc right
um you may have heard me say on this
show i was surprised yet not surprised
um i had a bunch of genetic work done
earlier this year and they told me i you
know i have something called the
cookie jar jean
and i was like what is that he said
it's not deterministic but you have a
leaning that when you get stressed you
get exhausted if you see an open package
of x y or z you will finish that package
and so discipline for you is less about
white knuckling it through things
it's more about you can never have that
in your house right so it's a genetic
it's a it's a leaning but there's some
behavior there right there's some
activity and action there so here's the
hard thing um again i'm not a medical
doctor
and i'm also not a geneticist so
i would recommend that you get some
genetic testing done on your boys and on
you and on your husband have you met
with a doctor before
not about this okay now
um if you'll stay on the line when we
get done i'll give you the name to my
doctor um and he incorporates all
everything from your genetics to your
blood work to everything into hey here's
how you can change your life in a very
sp specific way um here's what's going
to be hard for your boys is that
they're watching everything
and so they are absorbing and learning
this stuff and so true behavior change
are they already showing signs of being
overweight
no they're very very skinny but my
husband said that he was very tiny like
that too and
they they do see a big difference
because
i i teach fitness classes i run
marathons and they see me and then they
see
their dad and i just don't know
i don't know how to
teach them safely
you can
so take take the family stuff off
obviously you and your husband have had
conversations about this this has
impacted your relationship in some way
tell me about that
um
yeah mostly just because i worry about
what the boys see and i don't i don't
want them to
think that having
extra weight is a bad thing it's not
it's you know as long as you're healthy
that's what matters
and i want them to not feel like
they can't do something because they
have extra weight or they may have extra
weight and see i don't even know
which direction they're going to go
they're still
fairly young right
um what is it about
does your husband struggle
does he enjoy
his his body i mean does he enjoy is he
unable to do certain things when you say
obese is he 30 pounds overweight or is
he 130 pounds overweight
he's probably about 150 pounds
overweight okay does he struggle to get
around is it something he
would love to change what what is it
about his situation that is keeping him
stuck
um he
no he's not happy with his weight he
does want to lose it he's a stress eater
and his job is obviously very stressful
so he
stress eats and then he
you know he's tired of having a hard
time finding the right pair of jeans
um
we have the boys and i and my husband we
have dirt bikes and we love to go ride
and he struggles he can keep up you know
he's very active
um as far as
his job mechanicing like he doesn't sit
around and do nothing
he's physically active he just doesn't
he has a hard time keeping up sometimes
with the boys if they want to play
sports if we want to go for walks or
bike rides does he crash when he gets
home
yes
just hits the couch
yeah he'll hit the couch he he naps
you know with well if he sits around for
a while which i sometimes do too you
know you sit around you get tired sure
i'll take a nap yeah
so um
here's the thing
your boys are gonna
absorb the quote unquote
way we do things or the way things are
done
through
models
through pictures
and they will learn how to be a dad by
watching their dad
and they will learn how to be a mom by
watching their mom or what moms quote
unquote do
and so
if you are worried about my boys
downstream behavior
then the number one thing you can do is
model different behavior
and that means
that you and your husband need to have a
hard conversation that starts something
like
you're 150 pounds overweight and i'm
afraid you're gonna die
are you worried about him
i am he's we're in our
early 30s um
he's been on
medication for pre-diabetes um
so
it's yeah it's very worse recently my
grandma died of diabetes so so you've
seen this you're watching it there's
going to be some some genetic
predispositions there
my guess is underneath
because at some point someone has to
decide this is what my life is worth
and the folks that i've met with and
again i'm not i don't specialize in
disordered eating that's its own world
and it's notorious for how challenging
it is
but with those that i've met with over
the years the conversation always lends
itself to this is just the way it is
this is just the way i am or
no of course i don't want to do that but
i can't there's this limiting script
there's this limiting story that they've
seen they've been told they've been
they've they've had modeled for them
and
often these are the most extraordinary
people and they are lovely and hilarious
they've got a great person they've got
to adapt right
and at some the ones that make the big
change are the ones that get to the
place where they say
my life is worth feeling good
the hard that it's gonna take to lose
this weight
to just
flip that switch and say today's the day
i start exercising today's the day i get
a less stressful job if i have to
today's the day i take six months off of
work and we scrimp and and claw and
scratch financially so i can get my soul
back and get my marriage back so i can
be a good picture for these kids the
words that keep coming to mind here are
change your family tree
and
i would be willing to bet if you've got
a family legacy of this there's some
sort of something going on there and who
knows what it is right did he have a
hard childhood
no no
okay
that's fantastic so um
ultimately it's him deciding i want to
live a different life
and
one of the greatest gifts you could give
those little boys
is a dad who says i'm going gonna do
something different
can i tell you mine on a much smaller
much more minor scale
um i'm late everywhere
and i am a wreck like i just i'm always
carrying stuff everywhere literally i
got in a wreck today not paying
attention i don't pay attention very
well
i'm usually thinking about something or
crafting i'm always my heads are in the
clouds a lot
and
i went into my son's room about six or
seven months ago and it looked like he
had just taken everything in his drawers
and dumped it out and i realized he
hadn't done that this is just how he was
living
and more importantly i walked back into
my room to tell my wife like we gotta do
something about that and i looked at my
side of the room and i was i just had
this moment of oh no like this isn't a
matter of my son
lacking character integrity or whatever
he's just being just like his old man
and i sat my son down and we actually
actually took him out and i said hey i
have to make some life changes and i
want you to come along with me
and the two big life changes are going
to be about being on time because it's
disrespectful to you to your mother and
to your sister and to our family into
our church community when i walk in
there 15 minutes late to my people i
work with um and
i haven't done a good job so all to say
is i laid it out and
i'm gonna become militant about having a
clean home
and that starts with me and you're gonna
know i need you to know i'm gonna turn
the tables on you in a way that i've
never done before and i've kept up my
end of the bargain and interestingly
he's followed along and it's been great
he does push back like i don't want to
make my bed i like sleeping in a huge
pile of way right but
he's it started with me sitting down
with him and saying i need to do things
differently and you can watch me and
you're coming along for the ride
and then in your world it's a total
we're going to shop differently we're
going to act differently we're going to
deal with stress differently we're going
to work differently we're going to
communicate with each other differently
probably need to get some mental health
professional to walk alongside him a
hundred percent should get a medical
professional with him and there's
something different when you go to a
medical professional and say
i want to lose some weight
um or i need my you know i got to get my
diabetes under control or i'm
pre-diabetic or metabolic syndrome any
of those things
there's something different when you go
to your doctor and say i'm done today is
the day we change everything and i need
you to walk alongside me um the doctor i
use is named dr gus vicary and he's out
of north carolina and he does a lot of
his work um
i don't even know if he's taking new
patients right now i just put us just
put him on blast but
he does a lot of his work um
mobile right um over the internet we
communicate back and forth and he's
one of the greatest men i've ever met
and one of the greatest scholar
researchers and he's brilliant
um and he takes everything into account
and it's also very expensive like i
don't i don't want to mention any i
don't want to give people the wrong
impression it's very very expensive to
have that level of attention and detail
what i would tell you all is
150 pounds overweight early 30s young
boys
the money's worth it if you can find it
if you've got it you can scratch and
claw and if you don't have that money
which is totally understandable because
it's expensive
um
go to your doctor and say i need help
i'm ready go find a psychologist or a
counselor in your area and say it's time
we're going to do the things to change
behaviors to change the way we think i'm
going to look in the mirror and say you
are worth
not having backaches you're worth riding
your motorcycles with the kids you're
worth changing your family tree somebody
has to stare down that forest fire and
say no no more
and kate that's that's what it's going
to come down to is modeling different
behavior and then being highly
intentional about teaching your kids the
right way to eat the right way to move
their body the right way to deal with
stress the right way to deal with hurt
the right way to deal with pain
but that's going to start with new
pictures and new models
thanks so much for the call we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan two hundred trust me that's triple
eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to joseph
man right down the street in nashville
tennessee what's up joseph
hey dr john it's honor to talk to you
it's more of an honor to talk to you my
man what's up
so um
i am
considering um
well my wife and i are considering
getting a divorce
i'm sorry man what's up or
due to uh her alcoholism she's
she's struggled with alcohol ever since
i've known her we've been married for
eight years
my question is i
worry about
if we were to split up
we've got two little kids four and six
and i worry about
primarily their
mental
safety but also a little bit of their
physical safety if i'm not
also there to
monitor
what's going on
if your kids are growing up in the home
of an addict they're going to have some
some significant challenges
right
then dad leaving yes that will compound
the issues for sure i mean i don't i
don't know there's a lot here and so i
just want to be clear about that um yes
your kids are going to wear a lot of
this stuff when you say alcoholic what
does that mean
well um
early on in the relationship she was
very volatile as more um
the the problems tended to be more bingy
uh rather than like more of a daily
thing so it was more what happened when
she drank too much you know she would
shoot up but she had a temper anger
issues and
i mean there's a litany of of things
before kids that happened i mean she
punched me in the face she threw hot
coffee on me when i was driving
there's been some some stuff that that
stuff has all gone away
and now it's more
you know just daily
she will uh you know she wakes up very
motivated and
and gets stuff done gets the kids off to
school she's a stay-at-home mom i work
from home
and um
you know midday she'll start drinking
and it's you know it's between a bottle
and two bottles every day of wine okay
and um and by the time you know she is
the kids come home she's uh
just not not her best self i mean she's
a great mom when she's when she is um
sober but uh but
not as much when uh when she's not and
and it's starting to
kind of take over
uh impact every aspect of our lives um
you know she blows off plans with
friends she
um
you know she's just not present for the
kids um she's in in in our bedroom with
the curtains drawn and lights off
um and you know they want to play with
her and she
kind of shoots them away um that's hard
hard harder what's she running from
brother
what's she hiding from no
i don't know that's what i've been
trying to do i know that there's
something else underneath there and i
just don't know what it is yeah
yeah there's some there's some demons
there man it's heartbreaking yeah
i mean i know that in a previous
relationship she was physically abused
one time
um so i'm not sure if that's something
that she's just never dealt with or or
what but you know she didn't really
start drinking until
early 20s so it's not like a childhood
thing that started early and just oh man
those things lay dormant for years and
years and years right yeah and the more
as life stress piles up um
alcohol mimics um in a powerful way
alcohol mimics
um
the
it's like a cheap substitute for
relational
chemicals for lack of better terms the
chemicals we get from being in
relationship with other people being
connected to other people
sex does that and
alcohol does that if you if you look at
the two big challenges with college kids
and we maybe even talked about this
previously on the show but
you take 18 year olds from all over the
country and you pull them out of their
home systems and you drop them all in a
giant box
um
you've got a thousand brains screaming
for reconnection and a cheap substitute
for true vulnerable relational
connection is alcohol and
um sex
does she make
what happened now something happened now
that you said i got to get out of here
what is it
well there was an affair
um
a few months ago there you go um
and that kind of is what started us
you know i forgave her right away and a
one-time thing or did she fall for
somebody
um it was it was a texting thing it was
a violation of trust and then um i mean
i don't i don't believe that there was
more than that but there's been a lot of
untruths
and she hasn't really been honest um
about anything when confronted with
stuff like that and it's not the first
time that she's broken
violated trust so what makes agreements
in our marriage what makes you think
what makes you think they're going to
take the kids from you
where does that worry come from oh
where they're no i'm not worried about
taking the kids from me um no i'm i'm
more worried about if we were to share
custody 50 50
um her
her time with the kids alone gosh i'm
more worried about their their safety
yeah um and so
i mean
there's been a few instances where i've
been worried about their physical safety
with her
there's been some times where she's
definitely drank and then driven them
not often and less so since i've been
working from home just last year i
started working from home and
i'm able to monitor but there's been
plenty of times where i've had to go
pick up the kids because she's had too
much to drink or
or she's been out with girlfriends
at lunch and it turns into a three hour
lunch and then
i call her and i'm like where are you at
and she says i'm going to get the kids
and i could tell that she's been
drinking i said you turn around and come
home i'm going to go get them so
if i'm not there to kind of daily
monitor what's going on i'm just worried
about what happens and and
i don't know
i don't i don't want to try to take the
kids from her and try to get 100 custody
but i'm also feel like i'm culpable and
responsible for their safety as their
dad and good for you and all right so
listen listen to me carefully okay
yeah i'm gonna tell you something hard
all right this is gonna be hard
um
when you're going down this road that
you're going down right so we've had
infidelity we've had dishonesty we've
got repeated um
we've got breaches in marital trust and
then
you've got um
safety issues etc
you have to split this in two ways
way number one that comes first is the
safety of my kids
and your your instinct is right and i
heard you say it at the end there and i
love your heart i don't want to take
these kids from their mother
and what i would say to you is she is
screaming for somebody to please take
these kids from me before i hurt them
and you're her dad their dad that's your
job
okay and so
the any long-term what's this
relationship going to be i can't believe
you did that you stole my kids whatever
all of that is in the name of
i'm keeping my kids safe
think about it this way if a truck was
coming down the road and you saw your
kid in the street and you ran out and
shoved your kid as hard as they could
out of the way of that truck
and they banged their head on the
concrete and scraped their face all up
what you did was right
right that's what we're doing here we're
getting the kids out of the way of a
moving vehicle
the second thing is
is i don't want to read too much into it
because you and i just met but
it sounds like you love this woman and
you're heartbroken about what's happened
and
i would look at custody right now and if
i'm you so if i'm you i'm going for 100
custody because the kids are gonna get
hurt
um they're either gonna get hurt acutely
they're gonna get a car wreck they're
gonna get left somewhere because mom
drank too much or something's gonna
happen and as you go down the divorce
it's gonna get more intense
um
as her body starts to recognize there's
gonna be yet another relational
separation it's gonna get worse and
then
um
everything is about reconciliation if
she'll do the work to get clean to take
care of herself to deal with some of
this past hurt whatever
it would it's it would mean it would
fill your heart with joy to let these
girls go be connected and present with
their mother but they're gonna get hurt
acutely i'm sorry i cut myself off or
they're gonna get hurt like you
mentioned
they're gonna be tortured to death
slowly over time by saying hey mom hey
mom hey mom
and they are gonna absorb the message
that whatever else whatever phone she's
holding whatever glass of wine she's
holding whatever friends she's hanging
out with
they matter more than we do
and here's the problem with this
your kids know that part of them is
their mom
and when they start to hate mom or they
start to get frustrated or angry with
mom they start to hate and get
frustrated with parts of themselves
and then what do they do they start
looking for ways to fill that gap
and thus this stuff goes on for
generation after generation after
generation
and it takes a dad takes somebody who
loves these kids like you to say not on
my watch
and so this isn't forever this is i'm
going to keep my kids safe
um if you're going to go down this road
of divorce and i'm not here to say i'm
never going to recommend somebody get
divorced it's a mess
if you do that your job is to keep these
kids safe and to give your wife a path
back to you
if and when she decides to get healthy
and whole
how does that sound
yeah i mean that's
that's kind of where we're at
at the moment like literally this week
it's i've told her that
she needs to get treatment and and get
into rehab or else um
or else it's over
um what'd she say
she's fighting me on it
okay then she called your bluff yeah
and
i'm telling you
um
if you draw a boundary draw a boundary
i did okay
then you bought yourself into a corner
appropriately so and now you know what's
next right
all right what's next
well if she decides not to go then i'm
i'm
filing what's your what's your uh what's
your time limit
um i'm the kids are with my in-laws
right now and uh i told her i'll give
her until monday when they come back
excellent
good for you
um
do not do this by yourself okay what do
you do for a living
i'm uh in finance okay don't do this by
yourself
it's gonna be tempting to get an
attorney and just file the paperwork and
make this a a spreadsheet transaction
make sure you've got other guys in your
life that you can weep with that you can
call and see you got do you have those
i do yeah i know i've got two two really
close friends that i'm talking to daily
ex is that so good man and make sure
you're talking to him in person also
okay um make sure they're connecting
if there's any uncertainty in y'all's
conversation any like well if you don't
i'm thinking about
i think one conversation about fairness
and
it sounds like it'd be best to have it
in the morning when she's lucid and
sober and to say here's my deadline and
here's what happens after that deadline
and
be super super clear maybe even put it
in writing and so she can read it where
it says i love you you're the mother of
my our kids you're my been my wife for
almost a decade
i miss you
and you're being haunted by demons and
i'm heartbroken
and i i can't be married to someone who
cheats on me and i can't be
let my kids around somebody's gonna
they're gonna get hurt right and
an addict is great at deception and
somebody's struggling with addiction is
great at turning things around on other
people and hiding and dishonesty
if you write this down in a letter hand
it to her or read it to her and then
leave it with her
she'll be able to go back to it and go
back to it and go back to it and at some
point
she'll look at that thing and say this
man loves me this man really loves our
kids
and it might it just might be
that she gets a glimmer of hope a light
a small little light that
from your letter that says if he loves
me this much
maybe i am worth loving
and that's where healing begins thank
you so much for the call joseph man
we'll be thinking about you let me know
how things go give us a shout back in a
few weeks and let us know how things go
and hopefully your wife comes to you in
the next day or two and says i'm ready
i'm ready to go get help and i'm ready
to turn this thing around we thinking
about you man we'll be right back
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health
the single most important action you can
take to improve your mental and physical
health to change your entire life
is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life and for me good
sleep starts with a world-class mattress
that's why my family sleeps on dream
cloud mattress dream cloud is advanced
technology and you can buy in the store
or you can do it like i did and have it
shipped directly to your house
dreamcloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for dr john
doloni's show listeners 399 bucks and
accessories plus an additional 250
discount that's a total of 640 dollars
in accessories and savings pillows
mattress protectors luxury sheets all of
it it's time to stop sleeping on your
old college mattress or the old
hand-me-down from grandma and start
changing your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
daloni or dreamcloudsleep and enter
promo code delony and get your new
mattress today
hey what's up we are back let's take
unimas let's go to tori in
charlata north carolina and charlotte
what's up
hey how are you done so good how are you
i'm doing well what are you doing and
what are y'all doing there y'all having
fun
yeah we are having fun it's a little
chilly these days but
i am a little upset that uh nashville
mls soccer team just beat our new mls
soccer team getting started now the
other day
well i'm i'm i'm a little upset that
somebody mentioned that communist sport
on my show i'm just totally kidding
i'm not listen i'm not great at soccer
it's a lot of running and kicking and
those guys all look super
can i just tell you this i was in brazil
with my wife okay and
you know how like
in the states you can drive by like a
city park and they're playing basketball
um
you know they play basketball until late
in the evening whatever well in brazil
it was a thousand degrees it was so hot
so beautiful and it's like tropic it's
unbelievable and my wife was doing some
research at a was helping some schools
whatever and so i was just on my own
and
i drove by at late at night one of those
it looked like a soccer i mean it looked
like a tennis court like a basketball
court except they were playing soccer oh
my
it was the most incredible
it was everyone was beautiful all of
them were beautiful and i thought this
sport's probably not for me i need a
sport like fighting where everyone's not
that attractive it's cool so good for
you hey that's awesome tell your team to
pick it up they're terrible all right
let's go i know so what's up tori okay
well i am
a brand new labor and delivery nurse and
i love everything about it
um they're really really good days you
get to see awesome babies and crazy
stories and miracles and there's really
hard days too and
there's rare days that we lose babies
and babies don't make it or are born
not living
and i just feel like i'm not grieving
these babies effectively so what are
some tools that can help me
improve and grieve more effectively what
a great question
um number one thank you for being there
that's such a gift wow
um what drew you did that work
i
spent time overseas and
i worked with medical mission teams in
ecuador actually
in like indigenous communities in the
mountains and it was just such a clear
picture to me that like no matter what
corner of the world i go to health care
is needed
and they're birthing babies like if i
went into some specialties they you know
i might not be able to do it wherever in
the whole world yeah they're not doing
knee replacements everywhere yeah okay
very cool that's right what a great
heart like oncology treatments or
whatever yeah so
um i love it i love maternity i love
getting to meet women at that place and
that vulnerability and supporting them
and honestly it's it's so hard i don't
love um working with a woman when her
baby doesn't make it but it is a
privilege to be with her in those
moments too you know um
so what makes you think you're not
grieving well
i um
before working in labor and delivery i
worked in oncology and i worked at a
nursing home and
so it's not like i haven't seen death at
work um and it's not like
some lives are more important than
others
there's just something about babies um
and
we work you know after they're born
um
cleaning them you know having parents
hold them
taking pictures of them and it's just
very very hands-on and elaborate and
i've just been finding that
in eight months of working there it's
happened four times to me and every time
i messed up for days yeah like
connection with people is hard there's
little things that happen that just put
me in like a puddle on the floor and
um it's just surprising to me like how
debilitating it is again when that's not
something that's very new in my world
but
um like death in general yeah so i've
i've talked about it some on the show i
i pride myself on being able to walk
into the most bonker situations and yeah
um
twice
in my career i left my crisis so this
stuff i would do after hours i left my
partner and both times i said i gotta go
i have to step out of here which is a
big no-no
except i came to learn that it's a gift
and i'll tell you about it in a second
but
um
i had a little baby girl when josephine
my daughter was young she was one or two
um i went to one call that was at an er
and it was with a tiny tiny youngster
and
i'll never forget i saw the youngster's
arm through a crowd of people there
people working on her and my job was to
go tell the parents what had happened
and to sit with the parents while they
tried to keep this little girl alive
and
it was i saw six inches of her arm i
just saw her arm through a crack of
people and my body reacted in a way that
i was un i was caught off guard by
yeah and i found myself turning to leave
and like
like you i i would never do that you
know what i mean it was weird it was
almost i was grieving my own body what
are you doing
and yeah my partner janiece who i just
love she looked at me and said what are
you doing i said i gotta go i can't be
here and she's like you're leaving me
and i said i'm telling you right now i
gotta go and she's like get out of here
and we talked later and she said i'm so
glad you had the courage to tell me then
i said that's never happening again like
i'm going to flex and snap into a slim
gym and listen to some jaco podcast or
whatever like i'm going to be all in and
then
um
i was a part of a situation where there
was a mom telling her little babies that
their daddy had taken and died by
suicide
and that was another one when the kids
started crying i turned and said i gotta
go i left and for me two things were
important number one was knowing
your body knows
as well or better than you do
and
i had a little girl at the time now i
could do it now i would be fine but at
the time my body was recognizing those
stories running simultaneously and it
overloaded the system
and so
um
and then here's the other thing i had to
develop really robust processes for
handling that stuff you know what i mean
because i can't just leave every time
same as your job
so
when you say your body is
like
you're just a puddle for four days give
me some very specific things what does
that mean
um
i remember it was actually just last
week i had my most recent one and
i remember just being there like trying
to cook dinner with my husband and i
don't even remember what we were talking
about but there was just something
that set me off and i just had to and
i'm i'm not i'm really not like that at
all um
and even like my husband's coming he's
been like whenever something happens
with like our family or whatever you're
you know
like i i'm i'm a rock kind of person but
i'll just have to disappear and have to
like get out of the room and like
take a walk or something and
um what does it feel about it what does
it feel like
really heavy yeah
it feels like
it like every time it happens it's like
costing a really deep part of me you
know yeah put me there and be
with the family um
yeah it just feels like every single
time i i'm giving a part of me away and
it's it's heavy it's really heavy yeah
or sometimes it's giving yourself a part
of you away
i remember a few situations where i felt
like a part of me was taken
i didn't give permission for it i didn't
yeah when i show up to situations and
you know there's people who have passed
away here and there's dead people here
to people here i chose to walk into
those rooms and i'm okay giving up a
piece of myself in that moment because
i've got
other people who are right there with me
whether they're my partners or my the
greatest supervisor ever dr young um who
are there to refill right
it's when i go into a situation and i
feel like a part of me gets taken that
that's that's where it's unnerving right
that's it yeah
so um i'm gonna walk through a couple
things that i did and that i still do
and then leave you with um
one cool truth and one really hard one
okay yeah
all right so here's the first one
um and this by the way if you're
listening to this and think well gosh
i'm glad i'm not a like a delivery nurse
i'm not a trauma nurse or i'm not a
whatever
everybody experiences this stuff and
these are moments when your body
overrides your system that's trauma when
whatever's going on your body says whoa
we can't handle that and some people
fight it and some will run from it and
some people just go completely numb and
some people are able to go through the
motions and then
it shows up in it i call it this is a
gross word but we call it leakage right
if you don't deal with it it will find a
way out and it's usually at a real
inopportune time right like your husband
just gets home and he's leans in to kiss
you and you just start crying and throw
the spatula at him and he's like what
what happened
right it comes out at weird places or
you're giving a talk and also you just
start weeping and you can't get it back
right so here's a couple things um oh
one last question sorry do you have
young kids
no i yeah i've not been pregnant yet and
i think
that's another part of it is just like
it's very very easy to put myself in
those potential shoes you know yes yes
yes yes okay yeah
so
one thing i did and you've heard me say
this probably every show since this show
started
is whenever i would show up
to
be with somebody who had just passed and
the loved ones that were left whether
that was at a hospital with a
one-year-old or a six-month-old or a
two-year-old or i was showing up to a
house like you mentioned with a 98 year
old who had just passed away from you
know congestive heart failure and i was
with his widow right
whatever it was if i left that house
and i could tell it was still hanging on
me
i wrote that person a letter
and i told him who i was i told him that
i was going to be there to love their
family
and that i was going to make sure that i
did my best to take care of them and i
was so grateful for the time they got
spent on this earth and i wished them
well
and wherever they were going
and
but it was a moment of here's what i'm
doing i'm taking a body that has become
dysregulated it's been overwhelmed by
trauma and i am intentionally bringing
it back online
i'm letting my body know
yes we see this happened i am in control
i'm talking to this person and using
their name if i have it and then i'm
going to set this down
and there's a
highly therapeutic process
that just goes with that and there were
times i wept there were times i couldn't
it was a paragraph and that was it and
it was fine and there's other times i
wrote and wrote and wrote and wrote and
wrote
and those became some of my most prized
possessions because there were letters
to
like a lost child there were letters to
a teenager who died by suicide and left
his mom bewildered right
but it ended up being about me
being able to reclaim that part that was
taken from me
and it's a 30 minute practice it's an
hour practice you do it by yourself and
my guess is it's it would be really
healing for you
yeah the second thing is
this is hard but when you see that
happening
when you recognize
that someone's about to give birth to a
child who's passed away already or when
that baby is born and this happened with
my son
you you make eye contact with all the
other nurses and everybody knows this is
a big deal this one's scary my son had a
knot in the umbilical cord
and it wasn't it wasn't cinched it was
one of the most incredible things i've
ever seen um but i noticed having been
in a lot of those situations i noticed
all the nurses how they reacted and i
knew something was wrong right
um
one of the tendencies is to pull away
from mom and dad from that single mom
sitting there from the mom and the dad
and the grandma and everybody what's
happening was happening
this is gonna sound bonkers
but lean into it
yeah get closer to mom or dad
get skin to skin contact hold hands if
it's appropriate if you're able to if
it's welcome
hug
put your hands on the baby if it's at
all possible
go into it and give your body a chance
to process this thing not just rip it
from it okay
and what the tendency is when you walk
into a house and everyone's weeping so
loud is to be like whoa i'm not wanted
here
that's exactly where you got to step in
now someone may say get your hands off
me i don't want to touch anybody and
they're screaming and yelling and that's
hard and it's scary and all those things
and then obviously you're going to honor
what somebody tells you most of the time
somebody will hug you until you can't
breathe
or they will squeeze your hand until you
feel like it's going to come off right
there's something about leaning into
that instead of leaning out the third
thing that was really important for me
and again i mean i had the single
greatest supervisor boss friend mentor
ever going to call him dr andy young um
he changed my life man
um but after the heavy ones he would
call me
and it might be 2 30 in the morning 3 30
morning um how are you you doing okay
uh just want to check in on you what'd
you see and he would always ask what did
you see and there was something about
telling somebody else here's what i just
saw that again like writing it down gets
it out of my body so here's what i want
you to do i want you to have a couple of
friends that you can call
day or night
and y'all can do that for each other you
can have a text code that's like text
five five five five that means one of us
needs to talk right now
and then y'all can get on each other's
radar and you can just tell somebody
through tears and weeping and sobbing
and snot here's what i just saw here's
what just happened
and there's something about getting it
out and sharing that burden with you as
david kessler says grief demands a
witness you got someone's got to hear it
and see it with you okay
and then here's the last thing
are the last two things
when that
thought lightning bolts into your head
of that baby laying there
or when they you know you've seen them
do that um
it's unbelievable it's almost
disassociative when they're doing the
um it's a it's it's like a cpr thing but
it's that little bitty squeeze thing
they're trying to get a breath back
and that little bitty chest going up and
down it's one of the most heartbreaking
things you can watch
for me it haunts me
i will see that one again
and
what david kessler talks about in his
book is so phenomenal is
i can control my thoughts in the moment
that picture of that little baby who's
just passed away or that mother who is a
different kind of scream when a mother
loses her baby it's it's something
that's very unique
and when that you know i'm talking about
you've seen that i do yeah
um
it's easy for that to lightning bolt
back in our heads and then we just sit
and think about it over and over and
over it's our brains way of protecting
us so that this never happens to us
again
and what we have is a moment right then
when that happens to say i'm out not
doing that
off not doing it stop and i'm gonna
think about something else whether it's
a mother i remember laughing whether
it's a healthy baby whether it's
um a hug that i'm giving that father
who's weeping there i'm gonna
intentionally replace that negative
thought with something positive right
away and over time you'll learn to do
that easier and easier and easier and
scott now i've done it for so long it's
just instantaneous okay but it's
something you practice here's the final
thing
there may come a moment where you have
to look in the mirror sit with your
husband and say i love love love this
work
but this part of this of this is not for
me
and that would be hard and i'll be
heartbreaking i don't think that's where
you are
i think you you sound a lot like where i
was where i had to i was like oh i found
my body's limits i've gotta dig deeper
and i've gotta find new tools that i
don't have
um but i do have people that worked in
the crisis team with me that ultimately
said i gotta go like i can't keep going
into these situations um and so knowing
your boundaries is really important okay
and yeah you're not broke and you didn't
fail it's just your body's saying this
is what we can handle kind of like
like not everyone can be a lineman right
not everyone in a football game because
they'll just get crushed or like in your
silly sport that only scores one point
after 11 hours of playing or whatever
like not everybody can be a goalie right
not everybody can be a center forward
and so you got at some point you got to
know like hey this i love medical stuff
like but man the maternity ward's not
for me i'm going to go do something else
hope i don't think that's where you are
but just keep that in the back of your
mind there okay so i just do a lot of
issues isn't that helpful
that's really helpful i really
appreciate it awesome here's would be a
great gift
yeah i would love for you to
write a letter to the little baby that
passed recently
and i'd love to mail you you to mail us
a copy of it
and if you'll mail us a copy of it i'll
read it on the air i can do that i think
the world would benefit from hearing
how much you love somebody else
how much you love somebody else's baby
and i want you to hang on the line i'm
going to send you a copy of my brand new
book on your past change your future
that has an entire chapter on grieving
an entire chapter on forgiveness an
entire chapter on how to move forward so
hang on the line we're gonna send you a
free copy of that um thank you so so so
much for the call
and you're awesome hey thank you so much
for being in the lives of our
families and mothers and fathers and
kids and good folks as you hear in the
news
these nurses these nurses these nurses
i'll tell you what i've seen them i've
stood shoulder to shoulder with them
these nurses
[Music]
they are the adhesive that holds our
communities together we'll be right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now's your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be johndaloni.com to start creating
the life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are
back jack and listen um one quick note
on that last call
if you go to johnalone.com i've posted a
trauma guide and it's got multiple tiers
to it that just walks you through what
is trauma what's big t what's little t
trauma
and it can oh multiple tiers not like uh
not t-e-a-r-s tears for fears
tears layers of levels like a wedding
cake
that good weddings are trauma right dude
i'm not doing good i shouldn't hit a
brick wall this morning at 70 miles or
80 miles an hour
um anyway go to johnoloni.com you can
check out the trauma guide it'll walk
you through it we've gotten some great
feedback on it that's just helpful just
helps clear the deck cause there's so
much information out there all right so
as we wrap up today's show with the song
of the day james brought this in and i'm
just now turning it over so here we go
oh good god
[Music]
it's by carrie underwood
jesus take the wheel
[Music]
ooh kelly a little car wreck humor real
funny jesus didn't drive a prius though
she was driving last friday on the way
i'm not even reading this jesus take the
wheel
how about john don't wreck your prius
there's the lyrics read them yourself go
listen to carrie underwood it's just a
great tune
[Music]
can't do this on my own i didn't let go
carrie i held on to the prius and got us
here we'll see you soon